alright everybody this is our first ask
dave from our new studio we take
questions all the time you can go to
ruben report com / contact click ask
dave right there and you can ask me a
question and you never know I might
answer it so we got a whole bunch that I
wanted to get to today here we go Rob
says Twitter and Facebook are accused of
censorship of comments and people apart
from someone starting a new social
network site is there anything that can
be done is a boycott stupid or necessary
at this point okay so there's a lot
going on with this and a lot of you guys
have asked me about this and I'm
conflicted in what I think because look
I everything that I've built here which
I'm very proud of we've built on social
media sites YouTube is the second
largest search engine after Google
Facebook Twitter snapchat all the things
that we're doing we're part of this I
need these things to get my message out
and they've done great things they've
connected me with people literally all
over the world and they've connected you
guys with the ideas that we talked about
here so I love these things putting that
aside there is a massive problem with
censorship right now you guys all know
of course that Milo is the first person
that has ever been officially banned
from Twitter you could just go on
Twitter right this very second you can
find all kinds of crazy Nazi memes and
you can find all kinds of people telling
people to kill them kill themselves and
kill other people and all kinds of Isis
supporters and all this stuff but they
felt that this gay conservative should
be the first one officially banned now
I'm not defending every idea that Milo
has ever pushed as I have said to him
when he sat right across me from me here
I'm not defending all those ideas but it
has very little to do with about the
specifics of with what he said and
what's going on behind the scenes here
they felt getting rid of this gay
conservative who was getting extremely
popular was a good move and it's a
terrible move if you don't like what
Milo says I say this all the time you
don't like what someone says use your
speech to destroy it right really
destroy it with your own ideas you with
your better ideas but banning people
just pushes bad idea
is and and the grotesque parts of
society the more you push them down
they're going to come up and bubble up
in weird ways so I don't know what we do
about this I've seen just in the last
couple of weeks my friend feisal Saitama
thar who's been on the show and melissa
Chan and ali rizvi all who have been on
the show they've all had things removed
on Facebook so there's there's a problem
here the companies are trying to deal
with it they are all infiltrated hugely
with a lot of these social justice
warrior people and politically correct
people and we just have to keep pushing
you just have to keep pushing your good
ideas out there and who knows maybe some
other site will spring up that's fully
based in free speech and all that good
stuff and I'll jump on there as well
okay someone in the UK anonymous of the
UK says what's the deal with the
regressive left and religion
particularly their defense of Islam
aren't the left supposed to be atheists
do you think they actually understand
religion or are confusing race and
cultural issues so I don't think the
left are supposed to be atheists per se
but generally speaking people on the
left are the left the way we think of it
here in America are supposed to be more
secular in nature the right is thought
as of as more traditional and religious
those lines are being blurred as I
talked about here all the time as far as
the regressive issue with Islam yeah
it's a huge problem why do people on the
left the so-called progressives
relentlessly defend Islam which is the
reverse of all of their progressive
values you can go through the
progressive values wear fur gay people
wear for women's rights minority rights
etc etc these are all things that
everywhere that Islam the set of ideas
known as Islam is allowed to spread it's
a terrible place for all minorities and
women and gays and Jews etc etc and
Christians now so why do the
progressives put them at the top of the
oppression Olympics I wish I had the
answer to that but that's the point
that's why we have to keep pushing them
on this this this is crazy this
oppression Olympics and picking ideas
and depending on what group you're in
you should be grouped a certain way
either above and below another group
it's just silly and what we should care
about is the individual because as ayaan
Hirsi Ali says the ultimate
Nora T is the individual and I would
only want to be judged on my thoughts
and I would assume that's how you would
want to be judged as well michael says
what's that Sega Genesis game on your
shelf and are you a gamer so over there
I've got Herzog's we it is one of my
favorite all-time sega genesis games i
think perhaps the most underrated video
game of all time it was a split screen
strategy game sort of an early version
of like Warcraft and Starcraft and all
those games and when I was a kid my
brother and I my friends would have
sleepovers and we didn't want each other
to see the the split screen because then
you could see the other person's screen
you could figure out they were doing we
would build this crazy contraption with
cardboard and a string and we play
literally for all night long if anyone
out there plays Herzog's we I'd love to
hear from you it's one of my favorite
games oh and as I'm if I'm still a gamer
I was a gamer for a long long time I
really don't have that much time anymore
I really don't but whenever I have a
chance and I'm at my nephews and my
cousins or whatever and I can get a
playstation 4 or whatever it is I always
loved it Franco says hey Reuben I'm
really interested in hearing what your
thought was on the most interesting part
of your conversation with Tino San and
dodgy so for those of you that didn't
see my interview with Tino Tino's an
economist out of Sweden and a lot of
people had said that I should talk to
him about the immigration situation
there in the migrants situation because
Sweden is an extremely politically
correct society they've led a lot of
people into their borders and now
they're having problems the system's
having more problems there are rape
problems there are all kinds of problems
dan Tino is one of the few people
speaking out about it what I think
struck me more than anything else and I
fully I really enjoyed talking to the
guy he's really really smart and if you
haven't seen it i hope you'll check it
out but what struck me more than
anything was that a lot of people said
that you know the reason people in
Sweden don't speak out is because they
don't want to be labeled a racist and a
bigot you guys know all about this right
and it was like there was nothing watch
that interview I think we did about an
hour there was nothing even room
molle racist or bigoted about what he
said he was laying out complex issues
and saying 'can systems can state
systems function when they bring in a
lot of people who have a different set
of beliefs or maybe the that isn't that
much of a society that has had a lot of
different people there so then they
bring in all this and then do the people
that have been there maybe they do have
some prejudice like he really ran the
gamut of what the true situation is and
a lot of the things that most of
Europe's dealing with them that I think
we're going to have to start dealing
with here we have to have these hard
conversations and the more you label
everyone a bigot that disagrees with you
you hand it to the people that don't
want any immigration or want to kick
people out or stop people from coming in
Winfield says when it comes to forming
the new skeletal structure of non
mainstream media is there a system you
feel will be inherently better to
provide accountability and transparency
and quality reporting do you see a way
to scale up what you do or do you feel
there is another even more superior
structure to bring freelancers and
reporters together in a reputable but
powerful way I think the thrust of the
the question here is do you see
mainstream media crumbling and what do
we do to make online media good so to
the first part of that yes the
mainstream media is crumbling and they
should crumble they are just garbage
watch any of these news channels and
they are putting on former campaign
operatives to argue with people that are
super delegates to argue with people who
were still on payroll sometimes and you
know donna Brazile who is a who's I'm
sure a very lovely woman I have nothing
against her personally but she was a
democratic super delegate who was an
analyst on CNN then they get rid of
debbie Wasserman Schultz the DNC and
then they hire heard and then replace
her so now you have someone who's been
analyzing is now the head of the DNC
these and then you know she's sitting
across from David Axelrod who is a cab
AMA campaign advisor and then you have
your one Trump guy over there and it's
like this isn't news this is an analyst
this is this is back and forth dribble
so the important thing is that we get
more voices out there which is what I'm
doing and I I think you guys dig that
and that's great but we also have to
figure out this is the Wild West now
because any
with the webcam or a microphone or
whatever can get your voice out there
and while that's great that doesn't mean
everyone's going to hold themselves to
high journey listing standards or high
standards of truth or whatever else so
as far as what we do here yeah this
thing is scalable because this patreon
thing that we did you guys have given us
you know the the runway to build
something great and we have huge plans I
want to start a weekly news segment I
want to do some live stream stuff we
want to do more interviews I mean we now
because of what you guys have done on
patreon and paypal I don't have to worry
about making a deal with a corporation
that I didn't want to deal with or the
company I didn't want to work with or
feel that the message would be would be
changed in any way i can do deals that i
want to do so that makes it fully
scalable and i'm very proud of it night
and i thank you guys for it Jonas says
if you take a step back and look at
yourself in the mirror so to speak where
would you rate yourself on the
regressive spectrum from 0 to 100 a year
ago two weeks ago in today so look I
guess look I've always considered myself
liberal I was in it with the
progressives for a while you know look
there's plenty of video of me for many
many years now out online so you're
welcome to find some and see if you
thought I was regressive I don't think I
did much of the name calling in terms of
bigoted racist homophobe I've always
tried to take people's intentions and
understand what why do they think this
without automatically going to the worst
thing I would say I see it all much
cleaner now and as I've sort of had my
political awakening in the last year or
two once you start seeing it once you
start seeing what's really going on here
and you can break through the nonsense
on both sides by the way once you can
break through that nonsense and get a
clearer sense of what's going on here
everything starts to fall in place I
don't have every answer but I'm willing
to have the conversations about it
Jeremy says if we really broke
everything down just to singular issues
and we blocked out all forms of
tribalism I would think that most
Americans would follow the same centrist
spectrum with that in mind what do you
think can be done if anything to lift
people out of the shackles of identity
politics again this is a theme with a
lot of the questions you guys asked me
and it's a huge problem this identity
politics thing
people as Martin Luther King said right
you want to be judged by the content of
your character not the color of your
skin and that meaning that if you're gay
you should be judged by the content of
your character not your sexuality that
translates into every minority thing
that you want to go to we have to break
this thing I think that's why a lot of
people that are supporting Trump like
him because he's calling [ __ ] on all
of that and we have to I don't know that
Trump is certainly going to give us all
the answers on all that but I understand
what the issue is with those people why
they're attracted to it I think the most
important thing we can do is keep
talking about it keep talking about it
until people that are trapped in this
way of thinking force themselves to
break out of it and it will happen
because I see it happening all the time
and you guys email me all the time that
it's happening to you Rory says if any
what issue have you most profoundly
shifted your position on since the show
is started and who is responsible for
changing your mind I don't know that
there's an issue a specific issue right
so I think the same things that I think
about gay rights or about abortion or
taxation or things like that but I would
say I focus more and I try to think of
things now a little bit through the lens
of what the role of government should be
and that's why I talk about that a lot
you know we have two candidates right
now whether you love Trump or you love
Hillary or you hate them both they're
both kind of big government people Trump
says I'm the only one who could stop you
know Islamic to radical Islamic terror
and Hillary seems to want the government
to give you a lot of stuff and Bernie
wanted the government to give you more
stuff than even Hillary wants to give
you I would say the best government is
one that we don't have to talk about
that much because it's just working we
pay fair taxes and our roads work and we
have a strong defense so hopefully we
don't have to use it and we don't have
to go on fanciful Wars and nation build
and all that kind of stuff we give
people health insurance and we try to
have an economy that works but it really
works for small businesses and knock
crony capitalism so I think the role of
government is saying that now sort of
encompasses a lot of things that I talk
about now Jonathan says would you ever
think about creating a think tank to
spread the ideas of classical American
liberalism
and classical American conservatism I
believe that the two points of view can
be taught together and have a great
impact on our country when we have these
ideas working together our country
reaches its highest potential I mean
look I think this is the future which is
why I've said a couple times right now
if nothing else at the moment if you are
not happy with trump or Clinton support
Gary Johnson just for now at least get
this guy to fifteen percent even if you
don't think he's a good libertarian and
a lot of libertarians don't don't like
him for this reason or that but let's
get some other ideas in there about as I
just said the role of government and
what is classic liberalism and what is
real libertarianism let's get some other
ideas at the table so I'm going to try
at least for the next couple weeks to
help me like he gets to get into an
average of fifteen percent of the polls
to get into the debate is the guy going
to be President no is he going to get
into a second debate after that probably
not but let's have a bigger conversation
and we're having because our
conversation is dumb and everyone's
pissed everyone's looking around
everyone's pissed angry they feel stupid
being smart should not be counterculture
but it is right now let's make it
mainstream again Barry says have you
ever received anything resembling to a
death threat docks attempts or to get
you banned basically any of the worst
actions of the regressive left well
first off I would say that those things
can come from everybody you know I don't
like the progressives but that can come
from far right to it come from can come
from literally anyone of any political
belief and I have had some of those
things I've never been doxed thankfully
but I have had some of those things I
think it's probably left that michael
says can you tell us about your first
gig or can you tell us about your worst
stand-up experience overall so I used to
be funny that's a thing I was funny for
a long time I did stand-up in New York
for about 12 years and at one time I
think I was the youngest comic ever
passed at the comedy cellar which is the
really like the one like really cool
comedy club down in the in the East
Village and I did stand-up like six
nights a week two shows a night for many
years and I used to stand out in Times
Square i'm sure many of you have seen
this these barker's we used to hand out
tickets for two hours to get on show we
did it in rain or sleet or snow
and the worst experience ever had doing
stand-up I would say you know I only got
stoned maybe like three times ever
before I got on stage I never got drunk
before I got into a to anything like
that i was i was always very wanted to
be as present as i could be for the
crowd and one time I got on stage stoned
and I was just paranoid and awful and I
bomb terribly but but I am writing some
stand up again and my my funniness will
return Islamism not hilarious that's
what I've learned Carrie says how will
we survive the onslaught of negativity
from both parties that seem to do
nothing to change a person's opinion on
the candidate but rather ignite more
hate towards the other I mean this is a
great question and again a through line
through it so much of what's going on in
the country right now we need to stop
hating everybody we need to stop I
sometimes get lost in some of it on
social media to and again this also goes
to the role of government stuff they I
props as I could do this and Hillary
says I could do this and Hillary at the
thing all the speaker's kept saying
Hillary is going to fix this and
Hillary's can do this and Hillary can do
this it's like well you work for Obama
why did he not think of doing any of
these things so we just have a sort of
dishonest dichotomy and a dishonest
balance in the way our parties treat
each other the candidates treat each
other the media treats them they treat
the media it's a big game but it's being
unmasked right now people are waking up
to it and I think the best thing that
you can do is keep talking to people
about your ideas I really do Campbell
says what can ordinary thinking people
do to join the battle of ideas aside
from just liking and sharing videos
online or speaking to our friends what
what can we do well if you got a webcam
put your ideas out there do a better
show than I do I think this is pretty
good I'm doing the best I can but if you
can beat me to it I will gladly concede
one day when there are a thousand people
doing better shows than me based in the
principles that we've set forth here so
i would say that but really the things
that you address really are the things
that the average person can do keep
sharing these ideas keep don't be afraid
if you are afraid right now in 2016 to
share something because it's not
politically incorrect or because
someone's going to call you a bigot or a
racist or homophobic ablest
or another buzzword that doesn't even
make any sense if you're afraid of that
now what do you think it's going to be
like in four years we got to put the
stop on this thing now so we can roll it
back so that we can have the real battle
of ideas
you